hi straight in
hi hey can you guys hear me yeah we can
hear you loud and clear
okay perfect
well hopefully uh you guys are doing
good
um
yeah love your work pearls big fan
um usually I see your stuff on Tick Tock
until you get banned
um
but
that's uh that's where I saw this live
you know you guys started this up or
whatever Mr raw nice stuff YouTube
thank you very much
so it's okay I I I I know you have a
power it's okay it's fine I know you're
right you're just as good don't worry
but um so one of the questions I have is
is uh Pearl a lot of times you talk
about how men like today young virgins
mm-hmm and uh I just wanted to know do
you think that there's any value of
having like uh
like do you think there's any value of
having some sexual experience to like
judge if you and your partner are like
sexual or sexually compatible
um do I think there's any value for the
manner for the women
well for as it's been like from a male's
point of view is it good to like
personally I think I want to have a girl
who has a little bit of experience like
I don't know if I would necessarily like
if I had to have a lineup I don't know
if I would choose somebody who was who
was a virgin or and obviously you don't
want somebody who is you know like
like run through or anything like that
but maybe somebody who has a few
Partners who was in like trying to have
a real relationship with people and has
maybe like a few numbers under her bill
like under 10 or something like that
we're just having some like if because
if I know what I want and she could like
it's like almost like test driving a car
I don't know if I would want to
um like if the car wasn't what I like I
don't know if we want to commit to it or
I don't know does that like devalue her
anywhere I don't know
are you really are you religious
um so I grew up in religious but I'm not
currently religious yeah I mean I think
it sounds like you wouldn't want to wait
till marriage to have sex
not me personally yeah yeah so it's it's
kind of like if you get to the girls
what do you mean
well so like I I don't think I like I
don't want to wait but the I know you
say that that
um when you're talking to women you're
telling them to you know one of the
advice is like the younger you can be
and the less Partners you can have the
better for women yeah yeah exactly
so I'm just saying if you think there's
any value of having a few Partners or
like to see what you like what you don't
like and kind of experience do I think
there's any value no not really
um I mean I just think most guys with
their wife like the less Partners the
better
um but maybe some guys don't really want
to wait till they're married to have sex
so like it doesn't really make sense for
them to go for a virgin because they'd
want to wait you know do you think do
you think men should I even have sex
tonight
um I think for a virgin sure why would
you wait if she's not a virgin that
doesn't really make sense
what I'm saying do you think do you
think like men should be also allergic
to feel marriage
uh I I don't really have a strong
opinion on like what people do I don't I
don't really care if a guy wants to wait
like there's two strategies you could go
for so like some guys try to screw as
many girls as possible in order to
attract more women because like women
value pre-selection so that's like one
mating strategy guys do
um another one is to find a virgin that
you have similar values with and to wait
till marriage um
I don't I don't really have a strong
opinion either way I don't think it
affects guys as much as it affects girls
I totally agree yeah but as you show you
the root of the question is though like
that do you see how I would like want
more compatibility or like I'm not I'm
not a virgin but I don't I don't really
care if she is either to be honest
yeah um I don't think most what do you
think you think most guys want virgins
I feel like because when I'm talking
about it I'm talking about like guys
evolutionarily like that's what I'm
saying like like from a biological
perspective men want young virgins yes
in a religious sense yes however we're
living out most people are quote unquote
secular right and so
sorry most people are yeah okay
um
most men in these days and times are are
corn corn not corn addicts but they've
been watching corn right and so with
corn corn kind of
excuse your view on sex
and so
a lot of men are looking for a woman
so crazy a lot of men are looking for a
woman who can do the things that they
see in corn but they want a virgin but
they want somebody innocent also so it's
like men have a men have a lot of men
not saying all but a lot of men have
this this schizophrenic bipolar thing in
their head where they want their woman
to know all of these things that the
that you know she can swing from the
chandeliers right but be innocent at the
same time it's very weird
I'm thinking about your question more I
think data wise optimally it's two
virgins is the best that's what it says
yeah because I'm thinking like my my
parents have only like been with each
other yeah and I feel like it's kind of
better that way because like there's no
exes around town There's no like stories
of your parents like they're like that's
never happened but we don't necessarily
this is a thing po we don't live in that
world right now I know that that's
something that's why we got like when
they're like well like do you want to
Verge it's like well like The Virgins of
today aren't the virgins of yesterday
because the problem is and this is what
I've heard from guys like the virgin
girls of today like get curious
right and like that's why they're the
Virgin today is somebody who's had five
bodies
that's a version of today
like that's your like a version five
five bodies is that all you're a virgin
do you know what I'm saying like that's
the that's the version of today like the
[ __ ] of today someone who's had 20 30
40 right but the version of today
somebody's out of five bodies so this is
the thing is like we're moving with the
times in which we're living in
generally when you're on the dating
Market you know the dating app data
people on data apps are inversions
people on dating apps are not virgin
spells you know what I mean it's like
the lower the body count the better but
better religious and I just think for
guys it doesn't matter as much but for
girls it matters more
what do you mean like the bodies like
for girls they matter more like it seems
to affect women more than one effect 100
thank you for calling in
yeah you take care thanks yeah bye-bye
um
forgot about that I know I did too I was
like I didn't bring my laptop but I was
like oh yeah
um okay NJ
love your message hate to see people my
age I'm 20 listening to advice from the
woke stuff
um
how is Cheryl just left a very long one
okay hey freckles don't
don't read my super chats out loud okay
then I won't um never mind
was that like a press as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible